hey guys I'm so excited to be back in
the studio to film a new workout video I
know a lot of you have enjoyed my 10,000
steps challenge today's workout is going
to be another level up so we want to get
your steps in and also combine it with
standing ab exercises this workout is
slow in tag and is suitable for
everybody it's going to be a solid 25
minutes workout let's get started if you
have a pair of really lightweight
dumbbells then use it this is only 1
kilo each if not just use a pair of
water bottles ok so let's start with a
quick warmup I'm gonna put the weight
aside okay so let's start by doing a
little bit of dynamic stretches so I
wanted to open up your hips so just open
up to the left and to the right okay so
circle your hips out good left and right
good so we want to really work on your
lower body as well as your abs so let's
open up your hips keep going bring your
knee as high as you can
left there right left and right one more
on each side and good okay now stand
wide with the toes pointed up what are
we to do is stretch to the left and to
the right so try to reach for your toes
if you can't reach that's okay tap your
ankle okay keep going
stretch it up and look the opposite side
keep reaching you should feel the
stretch on your hamstrings
let's go two more on each side left and
right
twist and also feel the stretch on your
back all right good okay
feet together now let's just stretch our
quest mix up one two down up one two
good down again up one two
find your balance and good two more on
each side up last one more all right
very good okay so there will be a total
of ten exercises okay ten workouts it's
going to be low impact we want to keep
your body moving through other workout
and in between we will add in some ab
exercises so the first workout it's
going to be a simple march on the spot
all right so the work time will be 40
seconds with 20 seconds of apps good so
I just want to start marching with the
spot just relax the shoulders
step up left and right and remember to
stand tall okay so just gently allow
your arms to swing front and back really
relax your shoulders don't tense it up
we're starting off this workout easy
good you should start to feel the blood
flowing in your body keep going and now
what are we to do is just bring your
knee a little bit higher very good last
few more keep marching
just gently march on the spot and the
add workout will be a side crunch okay
so let's start on the right side crunch
it up up and up so it's about reaching
your knee to your elbow just working on
one side okay so do not drop your upper
body drive your knee up again if this is
too difficult just try to live as high
as you can
good all right now back to marching high
knee what I want to do is really driving
me up and just tap the opposite side
okay only 40 seconds so
squeeze a little bit and tap good so
really working more on your quads your
hamstrings as well as your glutes keep
going nice very good and we want to move
on to another ab workout which will be a
side crunch working on the opposite side
last one more and now step wide let's go
crunch and tap ok so point your toes out
and point your legs out feel the work on
your obliques your left obliques okay
tap down out and tap only 20 seconds
work so give me your best effort alright
low-impact jacks so hands up tap to the
left and tap to the right I want you to
really reach up stretch your arms good
this is a low-impact jacks so no jumping
involved rich and side to side ah
again this workout is gentle on your
knees so you can get your family members
to join you along last few more and we
want to move on to an app workout which
will be cross crunch
okay so hands up cross left elbow to
right knee and right elbow to left knee
again place both hands just by ahead and
drive your knee up keep going good if
you can't bring your knee it's high
that's fine okay all right now step kick
so what I want to do is start with a
kick step back change side step back
change sides
double step kick double stack and kick
good find that coordination step step
kick step step and kick
keep going remember to step back okay
don't look and feast right now good keep
going and for the next apricot if you
have a pair of dumbbells or any weights
use it okay one more on each side and
grab your dumbbells what are we to do is
a side Bend so left and right left and
right really been all the way fill the
pool along your waist and come back up
all right
good keep going through the pool go as
low as you can
and now drop the weights now that curl
so this workout will work more on your
quads as well as the flexibility of your
hamstrings so spread your arms okay also
stretching on your chest
good step come nice and remember to
breathe okay
you should be breaking a sweat by now
breathe last few more and grab your
weight okay grab your weights
hips russa what are we to do is step
wide place the win in front of you up
bring it back down bring your knees come
up back down in the middle up and down
okay
so point your toes forward bend your
knees lean forward drive it up
tuck your belly in and back down alright
dumbbells down let's go step and reach
so just point and reach I want it to
really twist it also and really engage
your core okay throw the entire workout
I weight to be conscious and engage your
core now let's reach up stretch it up
view the stretch on your left your back
okay stretch it up
keep going last few more and again grab
your weight if you don't have a pair of
dumbbells then do without all right
let's grab it Wood chop on one side
bring it up chop it imagine you're
chopping a tree bring it up really
crunch down up and down okay so only
working on one side reach it up
crunch it down up and dump stretch as
high as you can drop it in and out step
okay more challenge go low okay step out
go low step in I remember we're almost
halfway through the workout so I want
you to challenge yourself more step out
into a wide squat step in and step out
good haha and it's gonna be Wood chop
again on the opposite side okay step Oh
No push your butt back feel the work on
your glutes and step in last one more
huh grab your weights
okay opposite side chop it good and
you're working hard chopping that tree
keep going up chop it remember to bend
squeeze keep your knees soft up and down
last one more and down okay let's bring
your cardio up it's gonna be a snap run
okay so just on one side what are we to
do is imagine real running on the spot
but we're just working on one leg
alright so right leg static Drive to
your left leg back feel the burn on your
right leg okay good go as far back as
you can go as low as you can bend your
right knee and feel your heart rate good
you're burning calories and that's what
we want keep going last one more grab
your weights
more challenge balancing app okay on one
leg crunch it in if this is too tough
step crunch step and crunch okay if you
want more challenge lift your legs off
crunch step and crunch alright you
should be shaking right now
okay drop the weights the other like
okay so left leg forward right leg back
step and run let's go run okay keep
stepping back okay if this is too
difficult stand tall and just take a
step back okay for more challenge reach
for the back bend your knees ah you
should feel the burn on your left leg
last one more and grab your weights
okay challenge let's balance on our left
side reach it up squeeze it
tap down squeeze tap and squeeze good so
balancing exercises will really
strengthen your core keep going and drop
it down final workout side to side
touchdown step twice touch it step twice
touch it okay if you don't have a lot of
space you can take a single slight step
touch down and the reason why I want to
touch down it's because it's gonna need
more effort therefore it's gonna
increase your cardio even more
alright last workout and one more app
workout Oh
keep going 10 seconds nice shuffle to
the side
that's one more okay find an ab workout
just squat all I want to do is twist to
your left up twist your right and left
and right so we're working both on your
legs as well as your car again if this
is too much
stand tall and just twist side to side
alright good second run we're not going
to take a break okay we want we want to
keep our heart rate going
so first week out easy let's start by
marching on the spot okay
so take this time to bring a hundred
down if you need to pause this video go
ahead and grab a little bit of water if
not stay with me let's go much on the
spot and it spread on to 20 seconds of
apps okay slight crunch starting on our
right side ready let's go crunch it tap
and good so you know the workout let's
challenge yourself that little bit more
only 10 seconds left okay
so drive your knee up and drive your
knee towards your elbow last one more
and high knee okay that's tap tap tap
and twist
good so remember don't drop your hands
it's about bringing your knee up tap and
twist tap and twist oh I am sweating oh
I'm getting a really good low-impact
workout let's keep going
Kevin twist whoo breathe
remember to always pace your breathing
okay breathe in through your nose
breathe out through your mouth and we're
going to work on side crunches on our
left side ready let's go tap and crunch
good whoo hands go ahead working on the
obliques knees up working on your
balance as well as the strength of your
lower body which I'm sure you are strong
keep going last few more and low-impact
jacks so hands up step it out okay try
to go as wide as you can
bring it on as high as you can
good keep reaching nice oh it's raining
in here halfway there
step left and right and we want to work
on cross crunches okay so it's the
opposite knee to the opposite ten strong
hands let's go that's one more hands up
cross good view the coworking
remember to keep your body straight do
not hunched forward this is wrong hey
stand tall and crunch up and it's gonna
be step kicks so let's work on your
coordination kick step step kick step
step and kick
good one two three four one two three
four one three four good step and kick
there you go you're getting it remember
to kick with the ball off your feet and
if you can try to bring it higher left
and right very good
hah and we want to grab the weights okay
kick last one Laura cake
and now grab the weights let's go left
or right if you want more challenge
let's bring it up let's bend left and
right good
you will feel that the weight is pulling
you're on the other side and you want to
resist that by driving it to the
opposite side keep going
last one more and good let's hold on to
the weight okay let's go step curl drive
your driver heels to your butt and just
spread and squeeze your chest muscles as
well good so this should be a little bit
harder with the weight in your hands
again choose your option if you want to
drop the waist you can okay so remember
keep your feet wide apart
all right haha keep going
give me two more last one more okay hip
thrust
toes point the forward bend your knees
up down control up push your glutes
squeeze your abs up okay so it's not
about the strength from your humps it's
about the strength from your core that's
few more last one more and good now
let's hold onto the weight let's step
and reach and a little bit of punches
okay holding onto the weights let's go
punch it out well working on the
strength of your shoulders and arms as
well punch it up in one straight line
okay do not drop your hands step in
reach and remember use the power from
your torso and core keep twisting last
few more rigid and it's gonna be Wood
chop this is the fun workout reach it to
the opposite side crunch it down up
keep your knees soft okay pointed and
been good keep going
working on one side again you're
resisting the wait up that's one more
okay in-and-out step holding onto the
way let's go okay let's go low
hold onto the weight out and in good go
low okay it's a wide squat to a narrow
squat stay low and stay low okay now
let's just stay low do you not come up
okay stay low push your butt back feel
your glutes working step in and out you
can slow the workout on if you want to I
really wait to feel the burn on your
quads and your glutes give me two more
okay last one more and okay Wood chop on
the opposite side point your toes chop
it point your toes
chop and up good keep going down and up
up and down all right so let's challenge
ourselves and hold onto the weights
throughout the workout okay right leg
forward left leg back step run okay
Ronnie with some extra weights
let's go do the burn just on your right
side let's work on that let's work on a
total aches any strong car and a flat
tummy
let's go remember we cannot spot reduce
fat therefore in order to get its own
apps and its strong legs you got to work
on your total body okay good keep going
that's one more and balancing crunches
okay so stand on your right side reach
up crunch it in tap it out crunch it in
out and in good extra challenge lift the
left leg off the floor and crunch it in
ha keep going last one more okay left
sidestep run let's go Oh breathe you are
stronger keep going
do not stop right now you are almost at
the end of your workout and we want to
be doing a short and quick cool down
together ok so stay with me right until
the very end step left and right whoo
ten more seconds step back go low come
on push it good maybe with a burden on
your glutes
that's one more ok now left side ok so
you will tell to struggle on one side
more step
crunch it in step back crunch in step
back and crunch in good keep going bend
your knees keep it soft crunch it in out
and in that's two more one more and now
okay let's drop the weight all right
side tap down and tap down I want you to
stay light on your feet and just bounce
through the movement okay bounce keep
your feet light and tap down okay
remember bend your knees get into a
squat good ha that's ten more seconds
and it's one more app workout
tap down
few more last one low on this side and
step back up okay all right let's get
into a narrow squat let's just twist and
twist okay for the extra challenge stay
low
do not come up all I'm going to do is
twist to your left and to your right
Kayla's two more one more
oh and that is the end of your step and
also standing ab workout now let's just
bring our heart rate down and let's just
do a little bit of stretches okay so I
want you to just step wide and instead
of dynamic stretches we want to hold the
stretch so just reach and just hold it
we're not rushing to go anywhere so just
bring your heart rate down and breathe
in to your muscles change side and just
hold it okay remember to open up your
body to the left side so that you're
stretching on your back as well good
another of my favorite one of my
favorite stretches is to just link your
arms together drop and just swing your
body left to right this is a very
relaxing stretch and it's also really
good for your hamstrings okay
so just drop your body weight really
drop it feel a deeper stretch on your
hamstrings
that's one more
okay if you need to hold on to a wall
and we want to stretch your cuts out
okay grab onto one leg and just pull it
and again remember to stand tall do not
lean forward or do not lean back stand
taller right and now drop it let's
change the other side okay good
very good you have done really well and
in about 20 minutes
you should have achieved about one mile
okay so it's one bound of walking in
your own home okay and now just shake it
out shake everything out I want to just
take three deep breaths okay and sigh
out with me breathe in one two ahhh
really release all the tension breathe
in release all the tension go ah last
one more loud okay let's go together
breathe in deep breath and very very
very well done this is a great and safe
work out for everybody as it it's
low-impact it's gentle on your knees and
it will boost your cardio endurance so
if you're a beginner take this at your
own pace
alright and you can also combine this
workout with my 10,000 step challenge
remember to keep a worker consistent eat
a well-balanced diet and trust me you
will see results don't forget to also
check out other workouts and healthy
recipes on my youtube channel and do
subscribe to my youtube channel let me
know in the comments below what other
workouts do you want to see more of and
I will see you next time stay safe